American police have again killed
another good guy with a gun who happens
to be black a last week or the week
before I told you about police shooting
and killing a black security guard who
had a firearms permit who was able to
disable the shooter at the bar where he
worked and a bunch of reasonable
questions came forward from that
incident question number one our black
man allowed to be the good guys with
guns question number two why don't we
see the NRA sticking up for them and
creating public campaigns of support for
them as the law-abiding Second Amendment
heroes that so many white people receive
us as their treatment their PR treatment
from the NRA and thirdly is it that
clear that more good guys with guns
actually helps out in these situations
because it's gotten people killed so now
we have another incident to look at
licensed to carry black man EJ Bradford
21 years old was shot and killed by
police responding to a Thanksgiving
night shooting police showed up they
found Bradford carrying a gun and they
shot him dead much later they admitted
mmm turns out Bradford wasn't actually
the shooter we were called out about he
was a so-called good guy with a gun and
police were actually unable to even find
the actual shooter initially not the guy
they killed they weren't even sure who
it was that they were actually looking
for so still a question is whether EJ
Bradford was at all involved even if he
wasn't the shooter there are still some
details missing here but what has been
reported is that there were numerous
other gun owners most of them white
armed who were not shot at this event by
police and again these are the facts we
know and we need to wait to continue
learning more but the big picture is
that once again many people were armed
whatever went on in the officers mind
led to a split-second decision that the
black eye would the gun was more
dangerous than the white guys with guns
and that's who was shot even more so
than the active shooter okay now I'm
waiting
here from the NRA on this one I'm
waiting to hear whether they are going
to come to the defense of this legally
armed black man and the last one by the
way from last week or the week before we
still haven't heard from them about that
one either an investigation has been
started the office the officer in
question is on leave and unfortunately I
don't know whether we're going to get an
outcome other than hey you know what
heat of the moment decision the officer
was justified in what they did it was a
tragedy but the officer didn't really do
anything wrong and once again Pat you
know what why don't we hear the NRA
loudly and publicly come to the defense
of these black men who were legally
carrying and are shot by police I mean
I'm sure that they would say that they
want to get all the facts on the table
first before making their judgement the
problem is we know that they just don't
want to criticize police officers and
once that all the facts do actually come
to the table most people have moved on
not as many people are paying attention
to it anymore so then they can ignore
the story altogether that's my thought
on it the police will investigate
themselves and determine that no
wrongdoing exists by the officer he
feared for his life this was tragic but
it could have been prevented if EJ
Bradford had behaved differently oh and
all the other cameras that were in the
area they malfunctioned we just don't
have video of the incident it's
unfortunate I hope I'm wrong
okay I'm hope I'm wrong and we'll see if
the next 24-48 hours provide more
information about exactly what took
place here